[Music]
on this sunday night
the consequences for a canadian in china
michael kovrick goes on trial accused of
spying
a supposed trial an alleged trial that
doesn't meet the basic standard of
fairness once again canadian diplomats
are denied access
miami's emergency
the curfew to reign in rowdy spring
break crowds
racist reputation the canadian city
working to eliminate divisions
plus reflections of war refugees in
canada look
back at 10 years of conflict in syria
global national with robin gill
good evening and thank you for joining
us in just a few hours
michael kovrig will face a judge in
beijing charged with espionage
and like the trial for michael spavor no
canadian officials will be allowed in
court to watch the proceedings
the arrest of the two canadians is
widely seen as retribution for the
detention of mong wan zhou in british
columbia
at the request of the u.s and today
china had another contemptuous message
for canada abigail beeman reports
a former canadian ambassador to china
says michael spavor's connection to the
north korean leader
will likely be used against michael
kovrig during monday's trial
the chinese consider north korea as
theirs
and we know that sparrow had met with
kobrik and passed on information
but it's it's very easy for the chinese
to pretend that this was a
secret information but we won't know
what happens in court
china won't let any canadian officials
inside just like at spavor's trial
the one advantage that michael kovrick
has
is that his mandarin is better than
michael spavor so he'll be able to
follow
in more detail what is happening a
supposed trial an
alleged trial that doesn't meet the
basic standard of fairness of respect
for the rule of law on the west block
with mercedes stephenson
intergovernmental affairs minister
dominic leblanc
maintains the best way forward is to
work with other allies
but in terms of getting tougher on china
we are not ruling out
any action necessary yet another new
statement from the chinese embassy this
time
taking aim at comments thursday from the
u.s charged affair in ottawa
the chinese writing the united states is
the culprit and
canada is the accomplice many see the
timing of the trials as an effort by
china to use the canadians as a
bargaining chip with the us
but this week's first meeting between
china and the new biden administration
was
rocky unfortunately i think donald trump
as president
when he implied that he could maybe make
a deal with meng wong zhou early on
has probably led some in china to
believe ah
if we're tough enough this will enter
into it because they do desperately want
her back
global affairs canada says china is
obligated to provide trial access to
canadian consular officials and it
remains
deeply troubled by the lack of
transparency experts say
coverg may see more support outside his
trial with more diplomats physically
present in beijing than dan dong where
spavor was tried
robin abigail beeman in ottawa thanks
abigail
the campaign to protect canadians
against kova 19 is picking up steam
nearly 4 million vaccinations have now
been administered but there's still a
long way to go
the federal government may be in charge
of the supply but it's up to the
provinces and territories
to get shots into arms as heather york's
west reports
some regions are having more success
than others
essential workers are among those now
getting immunized against covet 19
in b.c it just means a lot to me given
that i'm in direct patient contact every
day with people of various ages so i can
protect them
next door in alberta doses are delivered
to people based mainly on age
just one of many differences between
canada's provinces and territories
as every jurisdiction pushes towards the
same goal
we are worried that with increasing
variance of concern
on circulation the goal is to get
everybody vaccinated as soon as possible
we asked dr brian conway the medical
director of the vancouver infectious
disease center to give each province's
rollout plan a grade
getting top marks yukon nunavut and
manitoba
followed by the northwest territories
and ontario
if you actually look at the three
northern territories right now
we see that uh that well over a quarter
of the populations
have been vaccinated that might even be
higher than that right now
whereas in the rest of canada you're
talking about well
you know maybe just about five percent
at the moment conway has given bc and
quebec a c
nova scotia a d and he's graded the
plans from alberta saskatchewan pei new
brunswick and newfoundland and labrador
as incomplete the structures aren't
necessarily yet in place or at least
people don't feel comfortable putting
them on paper in terms of the structures
that will be
required to uh vaccinate
two to two and a half million canadians
per week the vaccine rollout is still in
an
early stage and as supplies increase
every province and territory will be
tested more and more
missteps may be unavoidable but dr
conway says provinces who can course
correct quickly
and learn from the experiences of their
neighbors will likely have the most
success
almost on a daily basis to ask you know
what are we doing what are we doing
better what can we do better tomorrow
than we're doing today
and let's share that with all canadians
because with millions of canadians still
unprotected
this vaccine rollout has a long way to
go
heather yorks west global news calgary
a state of emergency has been declared
in miami beach where spring break crowds
have been getting out of control
florida is the third state in the u.s to
see over 2 million cases of coven 19
and massive groups of young people not
wearing masks were too much for city
leaders
who are now taking extreme measures
jennifer johnson reports
miami beach police are taking drastic
measures to enforce a new apm curfew
as spring breakers overwhelm the city
massive crowds of young people with few
wearing masks have city leaders fearing
this will become
another super spreader event if you saw
the photos of ocean drive
it was quite simply overwhelming it
looked like a it looked like
a rock concert you couldn't see pavement
and you couldn't see grass
so we feel that this is necessary for
weeks federal health officials beg
spring breakers to be careful
that many aren't listening
new cases of coba 19 are decreasing in
florida but rising in at least 20
states in other parts of the country
cases are plateauing
that is not a good thing when you have
that plateauing
that's usually the forerunner of another
surge
despite millions of cobot cases florida
has remained relatively
open officials fear the word got out i
think the volume is clearly
more than it's been in previous years
that i think is in part due to the fact
that
there are very few places open elsewhere
in the country
roads to the south beach party area are
now shut down after eight
something desperate bar and restaurant
owners didn't want to see
but police were losing control of the
crowds we've done everything we can
to try to mitigate the behavior that
we're seeing
but quite frankly i'm concerned that the
behavior is getting it's getting a
little bit more for
us to be able to handle the message now
to spring breakers go home
as south florida now braces for a
potential wave of new covet 19
cases jennifer johnson global news
washington
there were rallies against racism in
major cities today to condemn
attacks on members of asian-american
communities
hundreds of demonstrators filled new
york's union square calling out
anti-asian hate in the aftermath of the
atlanta shootings
six of the eight victims were of asian
heritage protests also took place in
montreal where a large crowd took to the
streets to denounce violence
targeting people of asian descent
the rcmp plans to act on recommendations
outlined in a review of how
officers acted following the killing of
an indigenous man in 2016.
global news obtained two reports which
say mounties made disparaging
racist remarks to colton bushi's mother
while breaking the news of her son's
death
the 22 year old was killed during an
altercation with a farmer on a rural
property in saskatchewan
but as global's nathaniel dove reports
the union representing mounties
is critical of the findings a civilian
watchdog says the rcmp
discriminated against the mother of
colton bushey on the night of his 2016
death
two reports from the civilian review and
complaints commission
found officers acted inappropriately
while speaking with debbie baptiste and
they had asked if she had been drinking
the review was obtained by global news
before publication
the rcmp's commissioner accepted most of
the findings
the officers union however is more
critical the national police federation
says the review dismisses or outright
ignores central facts and evidence
it calls the rcmp's acceptance of the
inaccuracies
demeaning to members in saskatchewan and
beyond and this injustice needs to be
called out
one lawyer says the conduct of officers
and the union's response
shows things haven't changed i think
that it belies
the same sort of uncaring attitude
and these scathing findings you're not
really surprising for first nations
people sadly
donald worm represented the family of
neil stonechild in the investigation
into his 1990 death that probe suggested
saskatoon police abandoned the teen in a
field
on a night when temperatures were close
to -30 degrees the denial of racism and
wrongdoing in the bushy case
adds further injury the rcmp says it is
implementing all recommendations in the
bushy review however
one activist working as an advisor for
the halifax police board
says that too misses the mark we have
seen a complete
abdication of responsibility an
inability
to have any accountability and in many
cases an excusing of the police
and a blaming of the victims both l
jones and worm say meaningful reform
must involve indigenous and local
community engagement
they say police can't just be
accountable to themselves
nathaniel dove global news saskatoon the
city of winnipeg has launched its first
ever anti-racism week the event is aimed
at improving the city's reputation when
it comes to discrimination
six years ago mclean's magazine labeled
it as the place where canada's racism
problem
is at its worst marny blunt reports on
the steps the city is taking
to eliminate the racial divides my wife
is
ukrainian heritage
my family is metis
i want my boys to be as proud
of both of those family lines a tearful
reaction from winnipeg's mayor
following the mclean's magazine article
dubbing winnipeg as canada's most racist
city
fast forward six years later we don't
need bystanders in the work of
reconciliation or anti-racism we need
active participants to combat
overt acts of racism now the mayor is
launching the city's first ever
anti-racism week
advocates say there is still a lot of
work to be done and dialogue is the
first step
plains article in this context at least
did spur some change maybe it might not
be as fast as some would like to see
i would be in that you know context for
sure but at least it provided some
mechanism to
encourage dialogue and discourse and
direction
to address racism in winnipeg winnipeg
is still afflicted with its challenges
more murdered and missing indigenous
women and girls a report outlining
racial bias among firefighters
and an indigenous teenager shot and
killed by police
prompting calls for justice from the
family i will not
stop fighting for my daughter no there's
no progress
um generally um awareness
by non-indigenous people um
has gone up planes and story
um it still works here it's it still
works here
even our scholars our world scholars
point to manitoba in order to study
racism and to work to eliminate racism
but dr lavalley says despite that
there is still action being taken to
fight racism
but but it's a start again if we can say
the word racism instead of cultural
safety or
humility or you know discrimination
it's really important for us to name the
thing the week also includes mandatory
anti-oppression training for more than
10 thousand city employees
something winnipeg's mayor says is a
step towards addressing systemic racism
and complicit bias
within government marnie blount global
news winnipeg
coming up will the u.s get the herd
immunity it needs
australia has declared a natural
disaster in new south wales where
record-breaking rain and floods are
being described as a once-in-a-century
event
some areas have now seen over 300
millimeters of rain since friday
it caused a major dam west of sydney to
overflow
evacuations and rescue efforts are
underway for thousands of residents
but officials warn fatalities are
inevitable
more than 43 million americans are now
fully vaccinated
that's 13 of the population and like
everywhere else in the world
there's a race to get more shots to more
people
to outrun those more contagious variants
but the bigger problem
may be the americans who refuse vaccines
entirely as jackson proskow reports
that could potentially keep the u.s from
achieving herd immunity
by late may there will be enough vaccine
for every american who wants one
the problem is millions don't i'm not
getting the vaccine because i'm honestly
not scared of the virus
i don't trust the vaccine at all
polls suggest a large number of
americans will refuse a vaccine
most of them are republicans supporters
of former president donald trump
how some groups would not want to do it
for reasons
that i just don't understand while only
11 percent of democrats said they would
refuse a vaccine
that number rises to 41 percent of
republicans
including half of republican men enough
to potentially keep the u.s from
reaching herd immunity
we're just going to still be living with
covet precautions
we're going to be living with cases and
we're still going to be living with
people getting severely ill and dying of
cuban 19. there are things we don't know
about the effects of this vaccine
conservative audiences have been
bombarded with vaccine misinformation
get vaccinated while former president
trump was the only one of the five
living past presidents not to get
vaccinated on camera
this week he broke his silence and
admitted there's a problem
i would recommend it to a lot of people
that don't want to get it and a lot of
those people voted for me frankly
in fact the vaccines were developed with
the support of the trump administration
two of the three shots used in the u.s
were given fda approval while trump was
still president
it's clear that the virus doesn't care
whom you voted for or if you voted at
all
and therefore we would like to extend
the protection of the vaccines
to as many people as possible
the biden administration is planning a
1.5 billion dollar campaign to promote
vaccine
acceptance much of the messaging will
focus on having trusted community
leaders sell the safety of the shots
in an urgent push to take the politics
out of the biggest public health effort
in a generation
jackson prosko global news washington
still ahead the war in syria 10 years on
how one of the 21st century's deadliest
conflicts
began
ten years ago hundreds of syrians took
to the streets to demonstrate against
president bashar al-assad
the peaceful protest quickly turned into
deathly clashes with police
and eventually spiraled into a
full-scale civil war
as mike armstrong explains the conflict
has now dragged on longer than the first
and second world wars combined
it has been a life lived in conflict
muhammad aburdin was born in northern
syria 10 years ago
as the country started to fall apart
with each year
things have gotten worse rohan mother
muhammad says he used to live in a house
and go to school
both were destroyed now that story isn't
just one of many
it's one of millions
conflict in syria has meant suffering on
an industrial scale
a british-based group the syrian
observatory of human rights
estimates that as of this month more
than 2.1
million have been injured and more than
594
000 killed they have been dispossessed
of their lands and homes
the united nations special envoy for
syria briefed the u.n security council
monday
he called the syrian people among the
greatest victims of this century
after a decade of bombings gassings
and starvation they have been injured
maimed
and killed in every way imaginable
their corpses even desecrated
the conflict started at the beginning of
march 2011.
the southern city of dara is sometimes
called the cradle of the revolution
15 students were arrested for
anti-government graffiti
within days protests exploded within
months defectors created the free syrian
army
and by 2013 refugees were pouring out of
the country
in every direction 5.5 million syrians
are displaced inside the country
another 6 million left they have fled
syria
often only to face further poverty and
discrimination or worse
perishing at sea in search of refuge
this was a rally in northwestern syria
last week to commemorate the 10th
anniversary of the uprising
it's one of only two small regions still
controlled by rebel forces
turkish troops control an area in the
north and kurdish forces in the
northeast
but government forces now control close
to 70 percent of the country
propped up by russian troops president
bashar al-assad has regained much of the
territory he'd lost
there has been a calm in the fighting in
recent months but many expect assad to
make a move on rebel-controlled areas
the only question some say is when
mike armstrong global news
up next mike armstrong's coverage
continues with the wounds of serious war
in canada
as we heard before the break millions of
syrians have left their country since
the start of the conflict 10 years ago
included in that wave more than 80 000
who settled here in canada
as mike armstrong explains they may have
found safety in this country
but the stress of what's happening back
home hasn't gone away
today we are preparing cuba
they are thousands of kilometers from
the conflict but it is
never far from their thoughts these
women are from syria now living in
canada working at a catering company
fatus its specialty is syrian cuisine
asked how often they think about what's
going on back in syria
nurmagome says every day
and then corrects herself every moment
she says while the fighting in syria
has calmed in recent months the
situation for people on the ground
hasn't improved in some regions
unemployment is running as high as
80 and 90 percent that as the cost of
everything has skyrocketed
the news about syria our pecsvalian says
is hard to watch
no she says it sometimes makes her cry
and that she doesn't see a solution
coming we
import the company was started by adele
tarzabachi
she's been importing soap and spices
from syria for years
when refugees started arriving in canada
she wanted to help them
well it's also helping the families
these women left behind
they almost all send about a quarter of
the money they make
back to syria even though it's hard they
need the money
even though they need the money they are
like obliged to think of their family
because they feel guilty that they leave
them there
tarzabachi was raised in the city of
aleppo today much of it is in ruins
when she calls people back in syria she
often hears
tears at the other end of the line and
people pleading for help to move to
canada
the 10th anniversary of the start of the
conflict may be a time for reflection
tarzabachi says
but it doesn't feel like a time for
optimism before we had like
a bit of hope right now
it's even that bit of hope we don't see
it
tarzabachi says many of the syrian
refugees around the world
planned on someday moving back even some
who came to canada
with every year that passes that dream
she says
is dying mike armstrong global news
montreal and that is global national for
this sunday night
i'm robin gill tonight your canada is a
frozen waterfall in alberta's waterton
lakes national park
thank you for watching good night
[Music]
you